OF.
>> Todd: NANCY PELOSI CAN ONLY
HIDE HOW YOU FEEL FOR SO LONG.
EXPOSED HERSELF NOW.
MEMBERS OF THE MEDIA USH ARING
TO THE PRESIDENT'S DEFENSE AFTER
HE FORGOT ABOUT THE DEATH OF
JACKIE WALORSKI, LISTEN TO THIS.
>> President Biden:
REPRESENTATIVE JACKY, ARE YOU
HERE?
>> IT IS CLEAR THE PRESIDENT HAD
A SLIP OF THE TONGUE OBVIOUSLY.
>> PEOPLE MAKE MISTAKES AND YOU
GO FROM THERE.
>> WE'VE ALL DONE IT BEFORE.
>> Carley: JOE CONCHA,
JO
NOW, GOOD MORNING.
THIS WAS A VERY BIG MISTAKE BY
THE PRESIDENT AND THAT IS HOW
MEET THE PRESS CHOSE TO COVER
IT, WHAT CHUCK TODD SAID, WHAT
DO YOU MAKE THAF?
>> CHUCK TODD SAYS WE'VE ALL
DONE IT, I'M CERTAIN WE, ALMOST
EVERYBODY ON THE PLANET OUTSIDE
THE MOVIE SIXTH SENSE HAVE NEVER
LOOKED FOR A DEAD PERSON AFTER
HONORING THAT PERSON.
BELIEVE ME, AS SURE AS YOU WERE
BORN, CARLEY, IF DONALD TRUMP
HAD DONE THE SAME THING ISSUE
THE NEWS CYCLE STARTING WITH
CHUCK TODD, WOULD BE OVERWHELMED
WITH TRUMP'S MENTAL STATE.
I TALK ABOUT IN MY BOOK "COME ON
MAN, "HOW WE HAVE GONE BEYOND
BIAS AND IT HAS SHIFTED,
JOURNALIST TO ACTIVISM AND THE
FORMER MODERATOR OF MEET THE
PRESS, WOULD NEVER SAY THE
THINGS CHUCK TODD SAYS ON A
WEEKLY BASIS.
TODD SAID THAT MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE ENTERING THE COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY COULD BE A GOOD THING,
THIS ADMINISTRATION DOESN'T STOP
AND ACTIVELY ENCOURAGES WILL
ONLY LOWER INFLATION, THAT WAS
CHUCK TODD'S ARGUMENT.
THE SHOW HAS BECOME A ABSOLUTE
JOKE.
>> Todd: NANCY PELOSI SAYING
THEY SHOULD GO PICK CROPS IN
FLORIDA, THEIR TRUE FEELINGS ARE
BEING EXPOSED FOR THE WORLD TO
SEE.
VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS
ASKED TO EXPLAIN WHAT SHE MEANT
WHEN SHE SAID PRESIDENT BIDEN
WOULD TAKE EQUITY INTO ACCOUNT
WHEN DISPENSING HURRICANE
RELIEF.
LISTEN.
>> Vice President Harris: IT IS
OUR LOWEST INCOME COMMUNITIES
AND COMMUNITIES OF COLOR MOST
IMPACTED.
WE HAVE TO ADDRESS THIS IN WAY
GIVING RESOURCES BASED ON
EQUITY.
>> CAN YOU CLARIFY WHAT YOU
MEANT BOO EQUITY FOR HURRICANE
RELIEF?
>> Todd: JOE, SHE WAS THE TOP
ATTORNEY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, SHE HAS TO KNOW THAT
HER EQUITY IDEA IS PATENTLY
ILLEGAL.
THIS IS DAY ONE LAW SCHOOL STUFF
AND I KNOW I SAY THAT ALL THE
TIME, ALMOST BEFORE DAY ONE LAW
SCHOOL STUFF.
WHY DOES SHE THINK SHE CAN MAKE
A COMMENT LIKE THAT?
>> Joe: THIS IS SOPHOMORE YEAR
AS FAR AS KNOWING WHAT YOU
SHOULD KNOW ABOUT THE LAW AND AS
YOU SAID, YES, SHE WAS THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF CALIFORNIA.
BUT OBVIOUSLY, THIS IS BASICALLY
VIRTUE SIGNALLING IS WHAT KAMALA
HARRIS IS DOING HERE AND SHE
DOES IT QUITE OFTEN AND YOU WERE
TALKING BEFORE EARLIER WITH
CHERYL AS FAR AS WHO WILL BE THE
2024 DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE IF JOE
BIDEN DOESN'T RUN AND USUALLY
THE FIRST CHOICE IS THE VICE
PRESIDENT, OBVIOUSLY.
EVEN DEMOCRATS, WHEN THEY SEE
KAMALA HARRIS SPEAKING ON A
DAILY BASIS, THEY SEE HER SAY WE
HAVE A GREAT ALLIANCE WITH NORTH
KOREA, FOR EXAMPLE, THEY SEE SHE
IS NOT READY TO BE PRESIDENT ON
EVERY LEVEL, STATEMENTS LIKE
THIS SHOW IT.
IF JOE BIDEN DOESN'T RUN, YOU
CAN BE SURE THAT KAMALA HARRIS
WILL BE RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT
AND GAVIN NEWSOM ALSO IN
CALIFORNIA WILL BE RUNNING,
HILLARY CLINTON, YOU JUST TALKED
BEFORE.
28 PEOPLE WILL PROBABLY JUMP
INTO THAT POOL RUNNING FOR
DEMOCRATIC NOMINATION AND
DOESN'T SEEM LIKE THERE ARE ANY
GOOD OPTIONS.
>> Todd: PICK UPPER YOUR COP OF
JOE CONCHA'S NEW BOOK "COME ON
MAN."
THE POOL, 28-PERSON POOL, HOPE
THERE